I can honestly say that I did every
mistake that you can think
of when uh every person that sits in
this chair is saying the sentence every
mistake every Pitfall I didn't skip even
a one even one Pitfall on on the
way um and that that was the best
business school ever okay when you do
things uh when you do a Hands-On work on
your startup it's your responsibility
it's you that uh that that need to bring
the money and to take care of business I
don't know if you see Seinfeld but uh
you see Seinfeld of course so Kramer got
a job one and they asked him Jerry asked
him what are you doing there and he said
TCB taking care of
business but that that is really you
know when you start a startup you're
taking care of business and your main
main business is to make sure that uh
you don't suffer from lack of of money
[Music]
so harell Ram welcome to 20-minute
leaders thank you so much for being here
how are you thank you it's a pleasure
it's a very nice place and thank you for
hosting me today I'm fine thank you well
thank you for coming all the way here
I'm really excited to have this
conversation because the work that
you're doing is so dear to me personally
like I mentioned to you before we
started' been recording the south of
Israel and beev and the ne are our
personal um personal have a personal
place in my my heart my my parents met
there H I'm getting married there I was
in my Army service I was tasked with
leading a lot of the logistics for the
transition of my army unit to the South
wow and so I got to visit a uh the uh
the high-tech Park quite a bit um I got
to know raote really well okay my Army
course was in
asalim and so I'm I I almost feel at
home around uh around and some of my
best friends from benon I love I love it
so much to speak to people that cherish
the ne and you know they know the ne
it's great it's great so we're we're
here to talk about Synergy 7 and we're
here to talk about the work that you're
doing today in the context of synergy 7
but take me back a little bit to your
own personal Journey walk me through
some of the major Milestones up to now
wow um I'm resident of the netive I live
in Omare my entire life
life and I graduated from benorian un
University in 1999 it was uh in the uh
past
Century um and then when you're um a
fresh graduate and you're looking for a
job in in the ne in Bersa in 1999 or
2000 uh you find out that there is
nothing there in terms of
Hightech so I started to work at Intel
in katat which was the um I think the
next stop from Beva where there was
something that related to Hightech and I
worked there for five years uh it was
great uh experience actually if you need
to start working somewhere it better be
in the one of the big American
corporates it's a school for business
school for doing things doing products
procedures everything is very
organized and after 5 years I felt that
I I need to move to something else and
then I went to the only company that was
in veva uh that was considered a
Hightech company called dallet video it
it deals with video uh for um uh uh
Sports newsrooms
Etc and it was the complete opposite
from uh from Intel it was a
messy exciting crazy Company software
company that digitized the entire
process the workflow of TV
stations I worked uh in in Dall for
almost 5 years and then I did the shift
from technical to business because we
were on the on the
um on the Two Worlds between you know uh
doing the technical uh um um customer
care and and pre-sales and actually
leading some project that that were uh
that came from the sales people and
needed engineering so I I started to
shift our business I I I saw a lot of
customers I traveled around the world
and I find this world very fascinating
it the business side was was amazing
meeting customers answering questions uh
writing rfps and and and
bids and after that I I worked for uh uh
several years in a satellite
Distribution
Company H and then I um so you're going
after the easy things so it's a Intel
video compression satellites the the
common easy stuff yeah uh and then uh in
2012 I
think uh that was
the that was the time where things
started to change in
beleva uh the the government of Israel
uh uh declared that the um high-tech
units of the army are going to relocate
to
Beva and that that started a some some
kind of a domino effect okay because um
loid Martin was then the integrator that
was that won the tender of of building
the data warehouse and then Ora Berry
that was the chief scientist of Israel
she moved to EMC which was bought after
that by
D and she convinced the um the EMC
headquarters that they need another
branch in Beva because the data
warehouse is going to build there and
EMC wanted to sell uh storage units to
this day the warehouse so honor Berry
started uh the multinational company
move to Beva wow she was I didn't know
it was Ora it it is Ora is an amazing
friend so so Ora I'm going to send this
right to you thank you thank you for
what you're doing OHA you know I speak
about you every time I get the chance to
interview so so she and she she really
deserves it wow that's amazing yeah so
Ona Ona was uh putting a site of a
multinational company without AP oling
without paying less without throwing
back the uh Legacy work uh in Beva and I
joined Ora and uh we I had a great time
at TMC with Ora and we've built the
Cyber solution Group which will connect
in few minutes to the
story ER and then after four years I
felt that something is uh you know I
felt something that caused me to to uh
stay awake at night and um I joined
three of my friends from dallet and we
started extrem EXs that was a bold move
leaving uh
EMC and starting a startup in Beva in
the
neev and I can say I can honestly say
that I did every mistake that you can
think
off when uh every person that sits in
this chair is saying this sentence every
mistake every Pitfall I didn't skip even
a one even one Pitfall on the
way um and that that was the best
business school ever okay when you do
things uh when you do uh Hands-On work
on your startup it's your responsibility
it's you that uh that that need to bring
the money and to take care of business I
don't know if you see Seinfeld but uh
you see Seinfeld of course so Kramer got
a job one and they asked him s Jerry
asked him what are you doing there and
he said TCB taking care of
business but that that that is really
you know when you start a startup you're
taking care of business and your main
main business is to make sure that uh
you don't suffer from uh lack of of
money
so um I I think that my biggest mistake
was the the way I funded this uh startup
uh the
um the power that we gave to one
investor and because on the uh
technology side we were brilliant I mean
we we we did something that I didn't see
it even today we did like Google docs
for media it means that a video editor
sits in Beva and he or she can edit a
video with a video editor sitting in Los
Angeles without upload or download the
uh the video and it worked like in real
time so it was it was a blast by
exchanging real quick metadata for every
action that you're doing and uh
standardizing that that we took the uh
the guys the the technical guys took the
h264 codc built a whole layer of uh of
real time on top of it and the
technology worked like
magic uh eventually we and then what you
had like was it on on your video video
editor was it on yeah we embedded it in
in Adobe Premiere wow and in Avid media
composer which was uh according to the
CTO the harder thing to do because it
was an API less
integration so he need to dig under the
uh media composer hood and uh write
right this integration on on the bare
metal of the aid composer and for Adobe
Premiere was a plugin on top of that
Premier was was was much easier W anyway
the technology was a blast and uh we met
uh Adobe in Vegas and they said that uh
it's a science fiction and we had a um
we had an agreement with avid can send
you the the story that the calcalist
made on this deal but eventually uh it
was blast due to uh mishandling the Sid
investment it was my mistake uh and uh
you know when uh you do foolish stuff on
uh when you start a startup you pay when
you want to
exit ER and then after the startup I I
took some time off and I was uh working
with people connecting them to money I
didn't take anything for that and then
my real journey was recover yeah yeah
you know you need to recover it's let's
talk about the mental stage uh or the
mental a um
state that you uh in after uh your
startup is blown away it's not an easy
one you need to
recover so I took the time and then uh
then the real journey in Beva started
what what have we have
today and I was thinking what I want to
do and basically I wanted to have
another
startup but my wife told me it's either
me or the new startup so I told her
let's pick the name for the new startup
I'm playing hero there no I I I told her
that I won't do another startup because
um what was it like for her having
nightmare yeah yeah it's a nightmare for
the family
you you told me that you're going to get
married yes I want to address your wife
and to tell her that uh please give him
the the space he will do his startup
best case scenario he will do an exit
and you will both live happily ever
after uh worst case that you have to
pick him and and give him to put back
the pieces put back the pieces and and
let him do another startup oh anyway um
I I was thinking what what I want to do
in my life going back to to work uh in
in EMC or Delwood whatever I started to
talk to a startup in Tel Aviv um we
exchanged some some contracts and I
almost went to to to be a VP in some
startup and
then Daniel which was
a the CEO of tech 7 tech 7 okay we are
talking we will talk about tech7 and
Synergy 7 Daniel was the CEO of tech7
which is an NGO sitting in Beva doing a
lot of good things
um they took the chter of being the glue
of the all the moving Parts uh of the
ecosystem in Bersa so we have the Army
going down and we have some venture
capital jvp and the friends of uh uh
there and we have the university and the
municipality so there all kind of DMC
and multinational companies and startups
that was starting to to formulate and it
it it is an ecosystem with a lot of
moving part and Tech 7 took the the
chter of being the glue of this moving
parts and Daniel came to me and he said
listen take Tech 7 I'm going to have a
startup he's a brilliant C brilliant CEO
of startup he raised a lot of money he's
doing fot Tech
now and I said okay I I took Tech 7
because I believe then and I still
believe today and I think to some extent
I proved it that Beva is a
stock okay and why is people invest in
stock when it it you know it it the
value of the stock is like one one cent
and I took the tech seven which was in a
kind of uh shaky uh um status it was the
2020 2021 Corona was uh raging and uh it
was difficult to to see the
future and we did an amazing do job in
Tech
7 we uh did a lot of um uh work for
startups with startups with
multinational companies we had project
in Mexico and Vietnam and Germany and
and it was it was very very good time in
in uh in
Beva and I started to see the the the
pie pieces are coming together
together in August 2022 the Israeli
Innovation Authority came out with a bid
um for promoting the city of
Beva it's a unique bid because the Ia
the Israel Innovation Authority is
usually a venture capital that invest
non- deled Venture Capital that invest
in companies okay this is under the law
the the hamop the law of
R&D and in this case it it's a little
different because they gave money to
promote a geographical area in
Israel so we've uh We've gathered the
the Consortium of companies that we have
today a Synergy 7 which is um benan
university with their Tech
transfer HMO uh with morum and
Soroka
Hospital Dell Technologies elbit system
and Mirage Foundation this is the
Consortium that is is now Synergy 7
and I I I believed in this Consortium
and I still believe and I think that uh
the stock is starting to to show very
positive signs because what we did we've
built three
Labs robotic lab with
elbit uh cyber lab with Dell and um
Soroka Studio which is uh a house for
startups uh for medical
startups and the biobank was so so we
put three major infrastructures in Beva
and we started to work with
startups and this is an amazing journey
I see we saw
250 ER startups in the past uh year and
a half since we established c
7 from you know all all stages very uh
two people with an idea up to uh serious
Beast startup that SS in the US and then
you know they want to conquer the
world and this is the time when I I
bring back uh or or pay back what people
when I started the startup people help
me a lot and now I'm I'm helping
startups to not to do the mistakes
because you know when you setting up
when you decide to to have a startup you
know what you're going to do the dos the
do list is very long you know that you
need to raise money and you need to have
a product and you need to go for
international sales and to go Global and
you got to have an office somewhere in
the world you know what the Dos are but
the
Dons list is very short try not to do
mistakes and sometimes I see people that
are doing the same mistakes that I did
or that are going to do mistakes that
are going
to to to cause the startup to bleed and
I try to to work with them towards not
to do the these mistakes but this is not
the only things that we're
doing yesterday the day before uh near
Barat the minister of economy was in
Beva at synergy7
office because we won another bid uh
from
the the um I don't know Ministry of
growth under the ministry of economy
there's a u um Department of
Department of
growth and we want um um a bid to build
another very important uh infrastructure
we are building two units in with Soroka
Hospital in Soroka hospital for phase
one
clinical er um trials and a
immunotherapy uh unit those unit are not
going to treat patient they're going to
treat patient but the essence is that we
are going to build
companies and we are going to uh build
companies that are that will
treat uh very hard uh
diseases in protocols that uh you know
the the next day
protocols uh which is very exciting
because sometimes it's even come before
the regulation the regulation doesn't
know how to deal with those uh
Technologies because they're very uh um
groundbreaking there are new
technologies and we are we we have
managed to put Bersa from a a place it's
not only me of course with all the the
partners and then the people that
devoted people that are working together
with me we've managed to put Beva in the
Forefront of technology and
Innovation and I think that you know we
haven't said the last word we just
started the companies that are going to
to um come out from this two units the
robotics lab that we have with elbit the
Cyber lab that we have uh with uh um
they'll they're going to be the the game
Cher the real game changer because
eventually when you build an ecosystem
you need to build a value for investors
if if you build something that people
are happy and meetting you know they
have
meetups and and they meet every month
and they exchange idea that's great but
at the end of the day if you want to to
move the
needle you need to create value for
investors you need not you want to be in
a situation when you don't chase after
investors they're they're coming to you
they're chasing you
yeah I'm still chasing the investors
yeah okay let's put the the um the r
status but I can see I can see it that
in few years will'll create so much
value that investor will start asking us
hey what's new what are you doing now
what you're working on and this is where
we want to be creating value so um it's
a stock as I said at the beginning Beva
is a stock the um smart
investors coming in now and the stock
value is still still
um uh uh reasonable I plan to um put the
stock very high um to put the stock
value on very high typ price and it's a
journey it's a journey and you need to
love it and you need to be devoted and
you need to come every morning uh to the
office and think what are you going to
do
next what is the how do you stay focused
but Invent Yourself over and over again
because
industry you know it's like stock market
again with this uh um example it it the
stock will rise
if you will Invent Yourself every time
uh
um from scretch and this is I think the
most important these are two vectors
staying Focus but Invent Yourself over
and over and this is what we're trying
to
do um I think that if you're asking
about building an ecosystem I think the
idea is to take money from government
that is willing to make make a change in
um um geographic area of of of Israel or
the state take money from the government
create value for the private equity for
the um
investors that will uh see the liage
that you did with this money and decide
to will will decide to come and join
your your
vehicle what what's different about this
journey versus running the startup
that's more product oriented it's a good
question um and I see I see a lot of
entrepreneurs me included that are
focusing on the product on technology
the CEO I'm talking about from the CEO
stand I see presentation 17 slide on the
product going deep dive into the details
and forgetting to take care of the
business side and I I I think that when
you start a startup your whole FOC as a
CEO
your you need to make sure that the
product is viable that you meet the
um Milestones of the product and it it
deviate you know the entire uh um
overseeing on the startup as a CEO if
you don't understand that the product is
need to be handle with product people
and you need to take care of business uh
you're in trouble what what I do is we
don't really have a product we have the
labs we have the um the road map that we
need to to uh be in charge of 100
startups over the four years it's not a
product it allows me to think
wider to have from day one to think
about the um partners that I want to
have in this journey to develop the
business to listen to the market I I
have some freedom because um we're not
not develop developing a product I have
another headaches because I have three
Labs uh which are you know actually
products by themselves but um those labs
are running managed by elbit and and
Soka and um and Del so I have the
freedom to develop the business now I
think this is uh this is the difference
it's it's a Nuance but it's a it's a
difference between nurturing a product
and nurturing uh a business or
um I would say we're taking care of the
negative okay and when you have this
chter when you have a um a growth of a
region it's different from having a
chart of of growing a startup and and
putting on it on CVS shells or or
Walmart it's a Nuance but it's it's
something that uh need to uh be aware of
absolutely well this was such a such an
interesting conversation hearing about
both the the the the the previous
Journey as well as this one and and it
sounds like you're you're on a very big
mission with a very clear Vision uh and
the stock and yeah and I'm and I'm a big
fan so I'm sharing from the side thank
you so much thank you it was a pleasure
I appreciate it very much thank you very
much and uh I hope you'll enjoy it I'm
sure everybody will watching than you